I Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
Star Wars just changed the way
they explain how the force works.
And one of the big reasons
is to avoid ever having
to talk about medical reasons ever again.
I don't think they've been mentioned
in live action since the events
of the prequels.
the interesting thing
though, is the new definition
or the new canon definition
for how the force works
is also meant to be more accurate
to George Lucas's original intentions back
when he was making the original trilogy,
even though he's the person who introduced
the idea of middle Chlorians
during the prequels.
Again, it's like poetry, sort of.
They rhyme so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, I'm
doing videos for all the Ahsoka episodes
and all the upcoming Star Wars series.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channels.
You don't miss that.
We're also doing the weekly giveaway too.
And since I've given away
all the Star Wars
echo dots we're going to do for Disney
Plus subscriptions.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and post your favorite moments
from Ahsoka on the video.
So far.
Careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on Ahsoka so far.
but during the recent episodes
they've explained that essentially
any living being in the Star Wars
universe can wield the force
the same way the Jedi Sith, my sisters,
these new Dark Jedi like Balan school
and chin hottie, can wield the force.
whereas before, a lot of fans treated it
as sort of like a force sensitive
and not force sensitive situation where,
like only certain people
could actually use the force
The quote that they used during
the Ahsoka series is meant to be a callback
to Obi-Wan Kenobi.
His original definition
for how the force works back in a new Hope
when he was explaining
it to Luke Skywalker,
When Ahsoka is
telling Sabine that essentially everyone
has access to the force that includes
non-human living things do in
when she clarifies that talent is a factor
in people's ability to wield the force.
What she means is that any random person
could theoretically train as a Jedi
and gain some basic skills.
But that doesn't mean
that anybody can become a Jedi or a Sith
or a nice sister in the traditional sense
to the level of people that you normally
look at as Jedi characters.
those ones are meant to be examples
of the very powerful Jedi,
very powerful, says Other force wielders
who are incredibly powerful.
that's why Hu Yang had that line
where he was talking about
the practical barriers
to entry into those types of orders.
the idea that even the darker groups
like the Sith, the Knight Sisters,
were very selective in that
they only took people
who had the greatest potential for power.
They weren't letting anybody at all
who had any kind of force abilities
into the orders really good examples.
This is the nice sisters.
Like every single woman
born to the nice sisters, didn't
automatically become another Knights
sister Darth Maul.
Zab Brack.
He was born to this knight's sister.
that didn't mean that
all the Zab Bragg people
that were born tonight
sisters were trained in the force.
Darth Maul is one of the exceptions
and his brother
that's why Ahsoka was arguing
with Hu Yang about one of the reasons
why she didn't agree with the Jedi Order
because she felt like Sabine
could become a Jedi, just like
all the ones that came before her.
But the order wouldn't have viewed her
as being naturally talented enough.
ahsoka's workaround
for that problem in present day.
Is it just trains being way harder
and she'll have to spend way
longer than it would normally take
for someone to become a full Jedi Knight
like Enoch and Skywalker, for instance,
who was born incredibly powerful,
incredibly talented.
they kind of got into this
during the Star Wars Rebel series.
When Kanan was training
Sabine with the Darksaber,
He basically said the same thing
that Ahsoka just said
how Sabine could use the force.
But internally she was having trouble
connecting with it because of past trauma,
meaning there was more of a mental thing
on her part
that she just needed to get past.
maybe because she doesn't have the force.
You don't believe she can do this? No.
The force resides in all living things,
but you have to be open to it.
Sabine is blocked.
Her mind is conflicted.
She's so mandalorian.
Very.
so Dave Filoni, who did Star Wars
Rebels, is is bringing forward
that idea into live action.
And this is the new overarching definition
for the way the force is supposed to work.
part of the reason
for this, for recontextualizing,
how the force works and explaining
how people use it is
so that they never have to talk
about midichlorians ever again.
the funny thing
too, is this is actually accurate
to what George Lucas originally intended
for the force. Way back
when he was making the original trilogy.
He just had a better way of thinking
about it, explaining to people,
then got a little crazy
with the middle chlorians
and making it all
about how high your count was
and actually trying to quantify it
like your medical origin count is a 1000.
That means that you can become a much
greater Jedi than this other person.
instead of just saying that the force
was this mystical Zen type of thing,
anyone could use it,
but had to be naturally talented
or have the will to actually do
what it took to learn how to use it.
this is George Lucas's original quote
about how the force is supposed to work.
He says a lot of people
get confused about the force.
They see it
as some special thing that you can find
and pick up and put it on your head
and suddenly you have the force.
Whereas it's always been designed
so that every living being has the force,
the amount of force,
which is like talent or intelligence
is different in every person.
Some of it is inherited,
but it's no more than a talent.
It's not something you can acquire.
It's something
that you have to learn to use.
That's also a way of explaining how Grogu
and other characters
can hide themselves in the force,
like sort of blocked themselves
from using the force.
And they slowly begin
to lose their abilities
and learn how to connect with the force.
Luke Skywalker had to help him
get over that past trauma
so that he could sort of unlock
that mental barrier
and reconnect with the force
and become more powerful again.
George Lucas
goes on to say, I have the power to lift
that cup off the table
using the force, but I can't do it
unless I've been trained to do it.
this scene of Ahsoka and Sabine
with the cup of tea, is Dave Filoni
basically working an Easter egg for George
Lucas's definition of the force, Like
he's making a reference to George Lucas,
his way of defining the force.
the other reason why
they're recontextualizing
how the force works is to correct some fan
driven head canon
that goes back to the old school novels
when they were
making the original trilogy.
So the actual term Force
Sensitive originally came from Splinter
of the Mind's Eye
and now non-canonical book
about an adventure Luke Skywalker
had between events in the trilogy.
I think it was New Hope,
An Empire Strikes Back,
and I don't think that the term force
sensitive has ever been used
in the same way in any of the Star Wars
movies or in the live action series.
It may have been mentioned once or twice,
but I really don't think
that they've actually done it that much.
would eventually wound up happening,
though?
After that book came out, fans started
using the term force sensitive
to refer to people who could use the force
versus people who could not
it'd be kind of like me
making up an explanation
for something about lightsabers,
even if it conflicted with something
that George Lucas said earlier on, like,
No, I never intended for lightsabers
to work that way.
So your fan explanation
isn't really valid.
this is actually a surprise for me.
I actually didn't realize
that the term force sensitive
didn't come from the actual movies
or from George Lucas himself.
Lego.
I've been thinking of it
the wrong way too, this whole time.
So when a lot of people were asking
when the series started
if Sabine Wren was supposed to be force
sensitive,
it was actually an incorrect way
of thinking about like the whole concept
was wrong from the beginning.
the new official definition
for how the force works,
and what Hu Yang and Ahsoka
had both personally said about Sabine,
or meant to explain that she can become
a Jedi like Ahsoka as Bridger,
any of the other Jedi.
She's just so untalented this.
She's like that kid
that you knew in school
who had to work twice
as hard to learn math or how to read.
Eventually they got there.
It just took them
way, way longer and way more work.
The other important thing is that
even though they're trying to get away
from the concept to medical reasons,
those technically are still canon.
So you can say that
Sabine has a lower mid a chlorine count
than someone like Yoda or Grogu.
You per the Jedi orders traditions.
They would have measured her
and barred her entry
because they felt like her
score would have been too low.
It'd be like getting rejected
from a college
because your test scores were so low,
but you could still learn
all the same things that you would have
at that university somewhere else,
which Sabine is now doing with Ahsoka.
get to go to force college somewhere else
that wants her
that's why Hu Yang made the comment about
Sabine becoming a nontraditional Jedi
like a soldier in how Ahsoka herself came
from a line of nontraditional Jedi
because she was trained by Anakin
Skywalker, very nontraditional.
He was a child of the force
and almost denied entry by the Jedi Order.
he came from
quite gone Gen who hated the Jedi Council
and disagree with them all the time in
Saigon was trained by Count Dooku,
who himself was a very nontraditional Jedi
in fact, he left the order
just like a soldier there.
Not too dissimilar in that way.
also like Grogu
rejecting the traditional Jedi order
that Luke Skywalker was trying
to resurrect at his Jedi Academy.
just to be clear, though,
Dave Filoni isn't completely retconning
any of the concepts about the force.
George Lucas introduced in the prequels.
So unfortunately we still have to live
with midichlorians.
But you can see how they're trying
to move past that idea to find a way
to recontextualize the force
so we never have to talk about them again.
plus their new way of defining the force
and how it works is more true
to George Lucas's original intent
for how it's supposed to work.
there's a lot of other stuff
that's happening
during this Sabine Training arc
that they're doing.
Like this is just the beginning
and I think a lot of her path
to becoming a Jedi will involve
what's really going on with Ezra Bridger.
So really expecting a huge twist
with that.
I know there are a lot of theories
about him
secretly being Marac or something else
going on with the character.
we'll probably get some answers about that
part of this equation pretty soon.
Hopefully.
Episode four Ahsoka will break his mask
and we'll learn once and for all who
he really is.
Do not be surprised if Merak winds up
being like a totally new random
inquisitor character.
There's not anybody special like he's
not meant to be a Canon version
of Starkiller.
He's not meant to be a dark version
of Ezra.
He's just like a totally different
character.
most of the evidence
is still pointing towards the fact
that Sam Witwer is doing The Voice
when he's wearing the helmet, though,
and his voice is being modulated
like the Darth Vader version of his voice.
The James Earl Jones version of his voice,
timing things out, though.
If Sabine eventually does
become a Jedi Knight somewhere
during the events of these next couple
of Star Wars series in movies,
do not be surprised if we still make it
through the first Thrawn movie
and she has not become a Jedi yet.
Like I think they're taking their time
with this.
it's kind of like Luke Skywalker's
progression through the original trilogy.
like, you didn't become a Jedi Knight
during Empire Strikes Back.
That's why Yoda was making fun of him
so much.
Like, Oh, you think you're a Jedi Knight?
That's hilarious.
It really wasn't.
Till we got
to the events of Return of the Jedi in
everything he went through through that.
But he actually became a full Jedi Knight.
do not be surprised
if Sabine does not become a Jedi Knight
till like the end of the third
Thrawn movie.
Hopefully they'll make it to a trilogy.
I think that's the idea.
They want to see how this
first Thrawn movie goes like this
heir to the Empire movie in.
If it does do well,
they'll do the full trilogy.
my Force. Okay.
Episode four Video We'll post next week
after they release it,
and we should get some more details
about what's happening with Thrawn.
I expect him to start popping up in
episodes in the second half of the series.
I don't think they're going to wait
till the very end before revealing
what's really going on,
there's a bunch of other big stuff
coming up.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click here for my Ahsoka
Episode 4 video and click here
for all my other Ahsoka episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!